where's ruffalo
mark what's up man you got awards in
there man
oh you know i i like to floss a little
bit unfortunately
i like the flex the gold a little the
little bling bling
baby
reminding me to remind me keep going
keep going man don't give up don't give
up don't quit don't quit
you'll never stop john first of all it's
an amazing film
and your directorial debut and by the
way
what you have accomplished you know i'm
watching this movie
and i'm thinking this is john's story
[Music]
in some way this is a reflection of
john's journey you've been fighting this
fight and breaking down barriers through
your whole career
you know i had a lot of trouble i was a
problem kid
you know i was almost expelled from
school because i was always disrupting
classes
well the acting has always been to
express
i don't know express a lot of feelings
that i think were bottled up
in me but you know it saved me getting
lost was the beauty of acting right
just getting lost in and not knowing
what you're doing and it just
happens oh my goodness
my goodness your accent is so soggy
we're going to have to work on that
horrible sound
you were creating like always just
creating
peace i hate the word
just spinning this boat all this
responsibility it never
stops i'm telling you all day long it's
clean this
change that take care of this no wonder
animals eat their young
your whole career has been this like
revolt
against the box that people have tried
to put you in
culturally racially and you've done just
a beautiful job man
i'll just take this one man thank you oh
i appreciate it there you go
be good you know you are that role model
for
young latinx people you know oh thank
you man
you're gonna make me cry
is that the right order right there
looks like it
oh yeah it is from top to bottom yeah it
is
right oh and you're even so you're done
now that's it can't do another one i
can't do another one because there's no
more room right
well i can move that book
as soon as i get up i start writing
rewriting
editing some of my children's books i'm
editing rewriting
my graphic novel on latin history for
morons my musical
kiss my aztec your work ethic
maybe it's just a fluke of nature maybe
it's just chance
no i'm an immigrant i'm an immigrant i
got an immigrant
work ethic because i don't know where
that duracell battery is coming from but
but it's got to be that
as an immigrant you just have this
incredible
hope and positivity because
everything now is so much better than it
could have been
and you always have that in your mind so
that always drives you
obstacles equal challenges challenges
equals opportunity somehow that that
mathematical equation
is in your head for everything
when we first came here when i was three
we all lived in
one living room no kitchen nothing
murphy bed so you lifted it up and you
had a living room
you moved over here on the other side of
the bed you had a dining room
you know i ate so much spam i thought
it's a spanish american
i thought this food is just for us we
eat it so much
[Music]
how did you get the name crazy legs like
johnny legs how'd you get yourself
i was always running away from trouble
for real
he starts over when they run away nobody
can say my last name so it was
johnny legs that's it because they like
grissom all the squeezing mo
zombie whatever so johnny legs
was a kinder version okay
[Music]
my mom she's a little bossy
she thinks she's good she thinks cause
i'm in in showbiz that she can direct
things from people you were very smart
extremely smart and extremely uh
too much energy very very energetic
hyper comedy
do you remember that i used to bring
wine
cheese at the american playhouse was
when i was playing
mumble mouth in the hallway yes yes i
wasn't even in the real theater
i was in a hallway before the real show
like look at six months
not three months later you were in the
main theater
i was that's right eventually they moved
me i forgot about that
you